so President Trump is set to get a very
big win tax reform is set to pass plus
rumors that the Trump administration is
going to move the embassy to Jerusalem
and Israel which I think has excellent
news and all of the breaking news on
sexual harassment and all these sexual
allegations there is one very big piece
of breaking news I will tell you in just
a moment
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
so really enjoyed my trip to Washington
DC it was it was very enjoyable I cannot
tell you anything about it
that's how secretive it was it was
magical but in any case there's a lot
going on in politics the breaking news
this morning is that Nancy Pelosi the
the house Minority Leader has finally
thrown John Conyers under the bus the
allegations have simply become too much
also the Jews 88 years old doesn't know
where he is shows up to meetings in his
pj's and sometimes dresses down in his
office so she basically had no choice
we'll get to that in just a second plus
I'm going to tell you all of the
allegations about Matt Lauer because Oh
gross
okay but before I get to any of that
first I want to tell you about one of
our sponsors
okay sponsor that will make you feel
much better when you listen to all of
the news lately
that of course is wink so if you need to
drink wink is the place to do it
wink is spell winc and they make it easy
to discover great wine the way that it
works is you go over to their website
winked try wink calm /ban and you take
basically a survey and it tells you what
kind of wine is best suited to your
palate what kind of wine is best suited
to a particular meal so when you want to
go over to somebody's house and bring a
nice bottle of wine you don't want to
look like a rube who just went down and
bought a bottle of Manischewitz at the
local supermarket now you can actually
bring a really nice bottle of wine that
tastes really great all the folks at the
office of had taste tests of link wine
and which is why they're drunk and so
bad at their jobs but try winked calm is
the place to do all of this again they
have that palate profile quiz and you
answer those simple questions and then
they will tell you what kind of wine
best fits your palate discover great
wine today the shipping is complimentary
go to try wink comm slash Bennett's winc
dot-com slash Ben you get $20 off your
first shipment
again that's tri wink comm slash Ben got
20 bucks off your first shipment tri
wink double T ry winc comm slash Ben for
$20 off your first shipment makes also a
terrific holiday gift you're going over
to somebody's house for Christmas
nothing better than bringing a nice
bottle of wine or buying them a
subscription at try wink comm / Ben so
pretty awesome stuff okay so in the
breaking news is that John Conyers looks
like he's on his way out John Conyers is
at last count 1363 years old he was
actually present not only for the
signing of the Declaration of
Independence but he was signing he was
president for the signing of the Magna
Carta but doesn't remember any of the
acts he's senile
Conyers has been hit with allegations of
sexual harassment he had to make
settlements with congressional money
meaning our money and earlier in the
week you recall Nancy Pelosi defended
John Connor she said he was an icon and
then she suggested that he should stay
and Al Franken should stay but Roy Moore
should go and everybody on the rights
and find will vote for Roy Moore then so
the Democrats are trying to put the
genie back in the bottle now now they're
trying to suggest that they actually do
have a standard when it comes to sexual
harassment and sexual assault Nancy
Pelosi the house Minority Leader
reversed herself today here's what she
had to say about John Conyers well the
allegations against congressman Conyers
as we have learned more since Sunday are
serious disappoint disappointing and
very credible it's very sad
the brave woman who came forward or owed
justice I pray for congressman Conyers
and his family I wish them well health
ever
congressman Conyers should resign as
dean congressman Conyers has served at
our Congress for more than five decades
and shaped some of the most
consequential legislation of the last
half century however zero tolerance
means consequences for everyone no
matter how great the legacy is no
license to harass all right discriminate
okay John Conyers you can hear his body
being dumped under the bus as we speak
bump that was John Conyers just going
right under that bus james Clyburn who's
the head of the Congressional Black
Caucus he came out today and said the
Conyers should go but only after
spending a week saying that John Conyers
had been elected so why should he have
to go the Democrats handled listen about
the worst possible way they should have
said all of this last week when the
allegations first broke if they wanted
to hold the moral high ground I said
earlier this week the Democrats had
basically given up the moral high ground
and that was a serious problem for them
that if you give up the moral high
ground then it's very hard for you to
argue that the Republicans should
somehow take that moral high ground for
Roy Moore for example or Donald Trump
the Democrats are trying to set up a new
standard which I think is a good
standard the sexual harassment assault
will not be tolerated but they're still
allowing Al Franken to stay so that's
gonna be the next shoe to drop there's a
sixth allegation against Al Franken
today apparently Al Franken did some
event in 2006 gave a wet sloppy open
mouth kiss to some woman on stage she
also grabbed another woman's ass this is
Al Franken's mo
we here at the Daily wire have been
hearing rumors that there is yet another
woman who is going to come forward in
the near future talking about a couple
of decades ago Al Franken acting in
sexually inappropriate ways in any case
Al Franken's allegations are credible he
has not denied them he has in fact
admitted them and so there's no reason
why John Conyers should go but Al
Franken should stay there really it's
it's difficult to imagine a rationale
other than Conyers was in the job when
he did this stuff in Al Franken was not
in the job when he did this stuff but
bottom line is that I think Franken will
end up going to I think when Franken
does go then it's yeah I think if and
when he does go that's gonna put a lot
of pressure on Republicans to dump over
Roy Moore or at least not to seat him in
the Senate I could be wrong on this it
could be that Al Franken stays and then
you have to ask yourself why is it the
Conyers go in Franken State Kirsten
Gillibrand of New York was asked today a
Franken should resign from the Senate
she said quote it's his decision which
means no he shouldn't resign he should
stick around so one of the things that
you have to ask his wife Librans going
and why Franken is staying one reason is
because Conyers is or Conyers going in
Frankenstein one reason is because
Conyers is as I say older than
Methuselah he's actually set world
records for his age he's in the Guinness
Book but and so he's not really very
valuable at this point like they
actually want him out of the House
Judiciary Committee because the House
Judiciary Committee will oversee any
impeachment hearings they don't want
kook old Conyers presiding over that so
they want him gone Franken is much
younger he was considered a possible
2020 candidate because we live in an
insane world so they don't want to dump
him over quite so quickly
if Frankenstein Moore will not only get
elected who will be seated in the Senate
if Franken goes then there's a good
chance that even if Roy Moore is elected
he won't be seated in the Senate but a
lot of it depends on how democrats
decide to treat all this now obviously
these are not the only sexual
allegations and these are not the only
sexual allegations that are out there in
breaking news literally this minute
Texas Republican Joe Parton says that he
is not going to run for re-election
after a nude photo of him was posted on
social media that was revenge porn as
you recall there was a situation in
which he had been he was separated from
his wife and he was sleeping with
another woman and texted a picture of
his ding-dong to this lady and then she
revealed it in public so now he's saying
he's not going to seek re-election so
we're seeing a huge turnover in Congress
right now and it's not just
just restricted to Congress of course
now we are finding out that the now we
are finding out all the specific
allegations about Matt Lauer so Matt
Lauer who was basically fired from today
yesterday this is according to variety
calm he once gave a colleague a sex toy
as a present it included an explicit
note about how he wanted to use it on
her which left her mortified okay
if she never reported that and the
company never did anything about it
that's insane that's insane
I mean you know how you know brazen you
have to be to do that to a colleague get
somebody a sex toy and right now like
first of all my guess is that what he
told her to do with the text why she
probably told him to do to himself but
it's really just horrifying on another
day according to Variety he summoned a
different female employee to his office
and then drops his pants showing her his
wing wing after the employee decided to
decline to do anything visibly shaken he
reprimanded her for not engaging in a
sexual act he would sometimes quiz
female producers about who they'd slept
with offering to trade names and he
loved to engage in a crass quiz game
with men and women in the office f marry
or kill in which she would identify the
female co-host that he most like to
sleep with so this is a two-month
investigation from variety there's also
an allegation that he did that while he
was married he asked an intern into his
office and then forced her to have sex
with him she calls it sexual assault on
Wednesday that NBC announced that Lauer
had been fired from today I guess that
they saved 25 million dollars in his
annual salary so he just blew a lot of
money in order to harass his employees
but the allegations are pretty are
pretty astonishing they're pretty
astonishing according to according to
one of the former producers they say
there are a lot of consensual
relationships but that's still a problem
because of the power he held he couldn't
sleep around town with celebrities are
on the road with random people because
he's Matt Lauer he's married so you'd
have to deal with in his stable where he
exerted power and he knew people would
never complain apparently he even had
his office was in a secluded space this
is amazing and he had a button under his
desk that allowed him to lock his door
from the inside without getting up this
afforded him the assurance of privacy it
allowed him to welcome female employees
and initiate inappropriate contact while
knowing nobody could walk in on him
according to two women who were sexually
harassed by Lauer according to sources
it extended to an hour traveled on
assignment for NBC apparently he paid
intense attention to a young woman on
his staff he found attractive focusing
intently on her
missions he asked the same producer to
his hotel room to deliver him a pillow
this is part of a pattern apparently he
would call various women who worked for
NBC late at night to his hotel room
while covering the Olympics so good
stuff from male our I mean the guy is
basically like the he's like a James
Bond villain he actually has a button in
his office that locks the door behind
you
does he have a is a hatchet man named
odd-job who's able to actually behead
bad employees with his hat it's pretty
incredible stuff I will admit that here
at the Daily wire offices I also have a
button under my desk that locks the door
but that's mainly to keep Michael moles
out but it's it's really like the idea
that nobody at NBC knew this was
happening there's such a lawsuit against
NBC that's burgeoning here there's such
a lawsuit that's brewing really really
amazing stuff so when these scandals
continue to play out and the less anyone
has standard the us the more of this
there will be as I said yesterday the
media actually does seem to have a
standard Garrison Keillor of NPR has has
basically been fired from his job over
allegations of sexual harassment he
denies those allegations I don't think
it's sexual harassment to force somebody
to listen to the Lake Wobegon tapes I
think that's just torture I think they
actually used that at Gitmo but
apparently Garrison Keillor was not
above average and therefore he has been
fired from NPR as well so the fallout
continues in politics the question is
gonna be what our standard is are we
going to hold the same standards that
the media hold for themselves the answer
looks like no a Conyers at least is on
his way out which is a good move he
should go Franken should go Roy Moore
should go all these people should go
they should all go and and there should
be a write-in campaign I know it's a
little bit late for that in Alabama but
that's just because the Republicans
didn't do the right thing the first time
they should have moved throwing more out
of this position in the first place okay
so I want to talk to you about some of
the good things that the Trump
administration is doing because they are
doing some good things believe it or not
and one of those good things is a big
shake-up that's supposed to take place
inside the cabinet I'll tell you all
about that but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at tripping
calm tripping calm is the world's number
one site for vacation rentals so I'm in
a weird position when I go on vacation
with my family because we really can't
stay at hotels not because I'm so famous
that people would be beating down the
door to get at me although that is
certainly true it's because when I go
for vacation I need to kitchen right and
keep kosher and so we need a place to
cook most hotels don't have a place to
cook tripping
komm lets you filter compare and sort
over ten million available properties on
trusted sites like VRBO TripAdvisor at
booking calm and more you don't have to
worry about if you're getting the best
vacation deal on that New Year's Eve
cabin or winter beach vacation you'll
save an average of 18 percent per night
by booking your vacation with trippin
comm so you're gonna get the best prices
and the best selection don't forget if
you want to save time and money while
booking the perfect vacation rental for
your next trip head to trippin comm /
Shapiro trippin comm / Shapiro go there
today trippin comm / apparel and who
knows you may end up in the cabin next
door to me because I use trippin comm /
capiro for all of my vacation needs
really it's a great service and I and I
really appreciate them so check that out
ok so when the White House is about to
make some major shakeups and I think
these are all good shake ups they're
about to get rid of Rex Tillerson Rex
Tillerson has been a garbage Secretary
of State he's really been inactive he's
not done much he up a 20 million dollar
a year salary text on mobile to go over
to the White House and be badgered by
President Trump so he gotta give him
credit for that one but he's been at
odds with Trump over foreign policy
because Trump is moving to the right on
foreign policy and Tillerson seems to be
you know center-left on foreign policy
he has apparently described the
president as a quote/unquote they
differ in their approach to North
Korea's missile testing and Iran's
nuclear program Tillerson wants to
uphold the Iran nuclear deal Trump wants
to abrogate it Trump is right Tillerson
is wrong so the plan in place is the
Mike Pompeo who's over at CIA and is it
has a good relationship with President
Trump would move over to state that
would be a definite upgrade over Rex
Tillerson whom I opposed not only for
his Russian ties but because I did not
trust him on foreign policy he also had
strong ties to oil regimes in the Middle
East and and so Tillerson would go he'd
be replaced by Pompeo and then Pompeo
would be replaced at the CIA by Senator
Tom cotton which is a really interesting
move it opens up another Senate seat so
it's a little bit risky Arkansas is
definitely a red state and the
Republicans would have an advantage
going in but it opens up another Senate
seat that really would not be open Tom
cotton I believe is still in his first
term in the Senate in Arkansas he's a
relative newcomer but he has a really
good record and cotton obviously also
has a military background so he'd move
over to CIA
Pompeyo would move over to the State
Department it's not clear if Trump has
actually made the move yet or greenlit
the move yet but it is clear that he
hasn't liked Tillerson right he's been
tweeting about Tillerson openly I talked
about this
over just a few weeks ago October 1st
Trump tweeted quote I told Rex Tillerson
our wonderful Secretary of State that he
is wasting his time trying to negotiate
with little Rokit so this is all a staff
shake-up overseen by the chief of staff
John Kelly no and I think that it's a
good move I think that somebody who
doesn't like Trump obviously the State
Department is leaking this at Tillerson
allies probably leaking this but this
would definitely be an upgrade and it's
pretty obvious the Tillerson doesn't
want the job he said earlier this year
quote I didn't want this job I didn't
seek this job my wife told me I'm
supposed to do this so he wants you out
Trump wants him out
so get him out and that's that's totally
fine with me I think that's a good move
by the Trump administration other things
that the Trump administration that are
that are good are that are happening
right now
so Trump is about to get his tax reform
bill this looks like this is going to
pass today John McCain announced that he
would vote in favor of the tax reform
bill I've gone through some of the pros
and cons of the tax reform bill it's bad
for people like me and California high
income earners who live in high tech
states doesn't work well for us it is a
across-the-board tax cut for everyone
else it's it's an across-the-board tax
cut in small measure for everyone else
there's some deductions that go away or
minimize the the child tax credit goes
away or is minimized there there's a
proposal on the table from Mike Lee to
expand the child tax credit that's not a
bad move but overall the bill is worth
voting for it lowers the corporate tax
rate that's something that definitely
needs to be done all the focus on
individual tax rates is is for political
gain but the reality is that individual
tax rates are not killing business
investments in the country right now
individual tax rates are too high for
sure by a long shot but it's the
corporate tax rates at 35 percent that
are driving people not to hire it's
driving people to to minimize their
their business investment because they
don't want to be taxed at 35 percent so
Trump is a Trump is out making the case
yesterday who's making the case on the
road in st. Louis it's it's a good sign
they get tax reform passed because
here's the fact if they can't pass tax
reform they're passing zero things
nothing gets past if they don't pass tax
reform and they also need to pass tax
reform in order so that there's any
momentum going forward on issues like
immigration or budgeting if they're able
to get tax reform through without having
to make any serious concessions with
spending then they are than they are in
solid shape for legislation in the next
year if there is any legislation to be
had
here's Trump in st. Louis yesterday
making the case for his tax cut the
beating heart of our plan is a tax cut
for working families that's what it is
this is not good for me me it's not so I
have some very wealthy friends not so
happy with me but that's okay you know I
keep hearing Schumer deuces for the
wealthy well if it is my friends don't
know about it he's right about that I
mean if you are somebody who is you know
wealthy if you're if you're doing well
then and you live in New York then
you're not gonna do well under this tax
plan
I wish it were an across-the-board tax
cut and not just you know tax cuts for
people who earn below a certain amount
but it is better than nothing for sure
and the main tax cut is not on the
individual side it's on the corporate
side the Republicans should have been
making this case all along it's why the
tax cut is unpopular because it was
pitched as an individual tax cut and it
really isn't an individual tax cut it
really is much more a corporate tax cut
the Senate adopted a motion to proceed
last night triggering a formal floor
debate over the tax reform bill all 52
Republicans voted for it including all
of the so-called moderates and there's a
new tax reform study that is out today
showing that the CBO analysis shows that
everyone's taxes will be reduced guy
Benson has a good write-up on this over
at townhall comm he's been all over this
so the this basically he shows that the
real real numbers show that your taxes
would be reduced by a not insignificant
amount particularly for the middle class
like proportionally speaking you are
going to you're going to see a drop in
your a drop in your taxes much more if
you're in the middle class than you are
if you are at the upper end of the tax
bracket so right now if you look at you
know various scenarios I'm looking at a
chart right now that talks about the
impacts of the Senate's amended version
of the tax cut and tax job back from the
Tax Foundation if you look at for
example let's take Sophia and she had
$165,000 combined married two earners
two kids they deferred $20,000 toward
retirement contributions they itemize
their their tax deduction under the
current law they pay about $30,000 in
taxes
the proposal odd they pay about $27,000
in taxes so they have an 8% reduction in
their tax burden every tax bracket
basically sees a reduction in their tax
burden of more or less quantity one of
the things that was pretty spectacular
and hilarious
about the about the way the Democrats
are treating this is that they are
they're lying about whether this is a
tax cut or not and then they're
suggesting that it's not good for the
middle class but what they actually want
to do is raise taxes on the middle class
right Ted Cruz had a debate with tape
with Bernie Sanders the other night on
CNN about tax cuts and he points out
that Bernie Sanders likes to talk about
he doesn't want to hurt the middle class
he's a liar everything Bernie Sanders
wants to pay for he's going to have to
pay for with massive tax hikes and Cruz
points this out quite correctly so
you're a single euro says you you're
gonna pay some more you're a small
business owner
he said pay some more and the reason is
there aren't enough millionaires and
billionaires know there's Haven for all
the social is what okay so he is exactly
right and not only that the Democrats
are so bollixed up that they even
refused to denounce socialism itself
right they can because Bernie Sanders is
a socialist Murray account well same
debate she's talking with Cruz and Cruz
asks her can you two find the difference
between a Democrat and a socialist and
she refuses to do it what is the
difference between a Democrat and a
socialist on taxes well you know Ted I
really thought about this issue of you
trying to divide the Democrats but you
know we're a big tent party and there's
room for Bernie and there's room for me
okay know that okay and then you want us
to believe that you guys aren't gonna
raise taxes obviously this is your your
goal is to raise taxes Trump is is
winning on this issue tax cuts our
winning issue for Republicans they
always have been winning issue for
Republicans their winning issue for JFK
they were winning issue for Reagan they
were winning issue for yes Bill Clinton
who had to reduce taxes after raising
the capital gains tax and they're
winning issue for george w bush right
tax cuts are always popular even if
people say they don't like it right now
that's because of the media coverage and
bad PR done by the administration and by
congress but once it takes effect and
your check is bigger in the mail then
it's going to be a benefit to you so the
tax cut is good policy and good for
President Trump for not watching it
right Thank You mr. president for not
batching this up there there are some
problems inside the tax reform bill I
wish that Trump would work to fix them
but
this is a lot better than nothing no no
question this is better than nothing
well I want to talk a little bit more
about Roy Moore the fall out there
President Trump doing some bad things
with regard to Britain and the hypocrisy
of some in the media about sexual
harassment but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at blinka so I
know that if you listen to this show you
are addicted to information it's one of
the reasons why you like the show is
because we just give you tons and tons
of information well blink is calm does
the same thing in a different way when
you're in the car you don't have time to
listen to a 600-page book what you do
have time for is a 15 minute packet that
allows you to go through the main points
of today's most popular non-fiction
works
it goes right through them it tells you
the things you need to know right in in
very summary fashion and they call these
things blinks okay you can read four
books in one day be just by listening to
an hour in the car because that's what
bling cos they over two thousand of the
best-selling non-fiction books
transformed into powerful packs that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and right now they have a special offer
for our audience go to blink it's calm
slash Ben right now start your free
trial or get three months off your
yearly plan when you join today
that's blink a spell bli n ki SC bling
cast calm slash man get your free trial
or three months off your yearly plan
once you try it you're gonna want to
stick with it because they have books
like why nations fail the two nations
indivisible they have a Rich Dad Poor
Dad you know the all these books they've
been sitting on your shelf you've never
had time to read the power of habit flow
dry a lot of books about
self-improvement in self-help a lot of
books about history go over to blinkers
calm slash man if you love to read
you'll like it even better once you have
an app that allows you to go through
books at the speed of sound blink is
calm / pen check it out blink is calm /
then okay so the Democrats the the real
reason you know I mentioned earlier a
little bit that that Nancy Pelosi had
thrown John Conyers under the bus the
real reason that Nancy Pelosi threw John
Conyers under the bus was not just
because of Roy Moore and they're gonna
pretend they have a standard on sexual
harassment it's because Nancy Pelosi is
is in danger of losing her speakership
to women Kathleen rice Kathleen rice is
a Democrat from New York
she's quite articulate she's very good
at what she does she's much younger than
Nancy Pelosi and she basically said
listen I'm gonna talk about sexual
harassment I want Conyers out I'm gonna
fight for this and there are people who
are saying that rice should replace
Pelosi so
he moved to cut her off this is why
kathleen rice the democrats to be very
smart if they were to move kathleen rice
into the top slot and and demote nancy
pelosi let's talk about the big elephant
in the room and that's why i was done
with the meeting i I don't have time for
conversations that are not real and I
for one I'm not gonna stand silent even
in the face of pressure from leadership
not to yep and the reason that she is
doing that is because she's running for
the top slot Pelosi is afraid of her and
that's why he that's why she is running
away from from John Conyers now so
basically don't give the credit to
Pelosi for Conyers falling give the
credit to Kathleen Rice who's putting
all sorts of pressure on Democrats to do
this maybe it's for political reasons
but whatever the reason that's that's
the right thing to do meanwhile if you
have any sort of bets down as to who is
going to be next in the sexual
harassment fallout I think that you know
let's just say that the Geraldo Rivera
might not be a worse bet the reason for
that is because yesterday after the
Garrison Keillor allegations in after
Matt Lauer was forced out at NBC Geraldo
had a bunch of tweets in which he
basically defended all of this he said
sad about Matt Lauer great guy highly
skilled and empathetic with guests and a
real gentleman to my family me news is a
flirty business
I really okay
news of flirty business and it seems
like current epidemic of sex harassment
allegations maybe criminalizing
courtship and conflating it with
predation
what about Garrison Keillor heard
well-regarded women in media today
suggesting morning shows go to an
all-female format that should be as
unacceptably retro as the other way
around I agree with that but then he
says reaction of my tweets today on sex
or accident makes clear I didn't
sufficiently explain this is a
horrendous problem long-hidden harasser
czar deviants who deserve what is coming
to them often victims are too frightened
to come forward in a timely fashion I
humbly apologize he did that because Fox
News told them dude shut it like what is
wrong with you defending mount our like
the allegations about Matt Lauer are
super serious and news of flirty
business is not a good answer okay I did
a morning show with a woman who I now
work with here at Daily wire Alicia
Krauss Alicia's like a sister to me
it's not a flirty business like flirting
only happens when you want to flirt with
your co-host
okay I did not want to flirt with Alicia
in order to Alicia wanna flirt with me
and so that wasn't a thing that's the
way that that your business is supposed
to work
the reason I say Geraldo may be on the
chopping block is because Garrison
Keillor
and the day before he was ousted NPR
wrote an op-ed in the Washington Post
suggesting that Al Franken should not
step down from his position defending Al
Franken the next day he was out at NPR
Geraldo's defending Matt Lauer
he's allegations been floating around
about Geraldo Rivera I was I didn't
interview with Chris Wallace yesterday
for Fox News Sunday I'm gonna be
featured on his power player segment on
Fox News Sunday I think a week from
Sunday and he we turned to each other
and we said are we gonna be like the
last two guys in media after office is
finished there are a lot of guys I think
in media who are not doing this but
apparently this was an epidemic okay so
in other news Roy Moore said something
yesterday that it just it shows you how
willing people are to believe things I
had a long conversation with my good
friend David Limbaugh yesterday David
and I been friends since I was 17 years
old David is one of the nicest guys in
in the business somebody who I think is
really principled supported Ted Cruz in
the primaries voted for Trump in the
general election there is strongly
supported Trump in the general election
he and I disagreed about that and David
and I were talking and we talked at
length about Roy Moore and he said that
he was annoyed by the number of people
who are basically saying that it was
morally inconceivable to vote for Moore
again he made the same argument that he
made during 2016 it's a binary call you
got a vote from one or the other it's
either Doug Jones or Roy Moore and Doug
Jones pro-abortion Roy Moore isn't you
may think that Roy Moore is a scuzzbag
but you know acknowledge that it's a bad
choice and you have to make it I've
always said I thought that was the
strongest argument in favor of more
although I think that you know points
for honesty although I think that it
doesn't wash for me because I think that
every you can't treat every election in
isolation if we keep saying that every
election is the only election that
matters then pretty soon very few
elections matter because we're just
selecting bad guys in every election the
whole point of this is that you preserve
your character so you can fight another
day you preserve your character so you
can have the moral high ground and
that's important that's my point
but I'm not begrudging people who make a
different calculation right I think that
I understand your argument I just don't
agree with it I may not agree with it
morally I may not agree with it and
utilitarian sense but I understand the
argument I'm not gonna pretend that the
argument doesn't have some weight it
obviously does but what does bother me
is all the people who are trying to
convince themselves that Moore is
innocent right there that Moore didn't
do anything at all I think that it is
highly unlikely and put it that way very
very unlikely that Moore didn't do
anything given in fact there are nine
women who have made allegations about
Roy Moore
yesterday Roy Moore was trotting out his
latest conspiracy theory and this is
what drives me nuts about the partisan
hackery of all of this is that if you
wildly allege things then people on your
own side will buy into it so long as it
serves their political purposes here's
what Roy Moore had to say about how
these allegations came to their ego
essentially saying that the people who
are trying to stop him are all liberals
they're lesbian gay bisexual transgender
who want to change our culture the
Socialists are behind these allegations
okay the two women who are behind the
allegations are apparently that behind
the main allegations one says that she
was 16 when Roy Moore took her out into
his car and essentially tried to rape
her that's the one with the ear book and
then the other woman who came forward
and said she was 14 when Roy Moore took
her home and tried to molest her both of
these women are from supporters they're
white straight Trump supporters so no
this is not just about the quote-unquote
liberal agenda it is about whether Roy
Moore did this stuff or not for a lot of
these people but as long as you're
willing to put everything in the box of
conspiratorial ISM you're well you're
able to get away with everything and
you're seeing that now mores best
supporters are moving this direction
they can't deal with the cognitive
dissonance of just saying Roy Moore may
have done some really bad stuff years
ago and like really bad stuff years ago
but we're gonna vote from anyway which
is what K IV the governor of Alabama was
honest enough to say now they're trying
to rehabilitate Moore and say that all
of this is nonsense which again I think
this puts us in a very difficult
position if you're trying to be
intellectually honest
here's mo Brooks who ran against Moore
in the primaries and lost saying that
the yearbook is forged the woman who
alleges that Moore signed her yearbook
and then tried to rape her basically
that that yearbook is forged there are
only two they have thirty that room
engaged in unlawful conduct one of those
is clearly a liar because that one
forged the love really more part of a
yearbook in order to try to or whatever
reason get a Troi more and win the seat
for the Democrats there's a lot more to
it as to why I believe that the evidence
is almost uncontroverted all about
whether the yearbook was forced so now
you're down to one witness and and you
look at the preponderance of the
evidence and then you had one Morris
denial in it you add his long deeply
held Christian beliefs and I just don't
think there's anywhere in the world that
a jury would agree with the assertions
of the Washington Post so the
allegations of the yearbook are faked it
said that be the weirdest story ever if
the yearbook or indeed Forge and there's
a second allegation by a woman who has
nothing to do with the yearbook so again
deal with the cognitive dissonance okay
if you want to own it own it if you want
to say listen we have to elect bad guys
because they're worse guys out there we
have to stop own that argument but do
not recast evidence do not pretend bad
things didn't happen because it's
uncomfortable for you to admit that
you're voting for a guy who's done some
pretty terrible things or who's
allegedly done some pretty terrible
things okay so meanwhile president Trump
who I praised before on policy I was
asked by a member of the administration
very recently how I thought that the
administration was doing overall and
what I said was this I said if I had to
grade them I give them an a on executive
policy I'd give them a C on negotiations
with Congress and I give them a D on
communication and that seems to be the
pattern right and that's that's sort of
how today's show is on policy the Trump
administration is about to get tax
reform done they are about to make some
good moves with regard to Jerusalem
there's a strong rumor coming out of the
White House that the that the
administration is about to move the
embassy if not movie embassy to
Jerusalem in Israel to declare Jerusalem
the capital of Israel that would be
great I have a niece who was born in
Jerusalem and her passport just says
Jerusalem it doesn't say Jerusalem
Israel because the State Department
refused to recognize that Jerusalem is a
part of Israel even though it has been
the eternal and will be the eternal
capital of Israel for all of time in any
case that all of this is very good
policy so a for that in terms of
negotiation with Congress again
the administration is not totally to
blame because Congress had been very
fractious but they haven't been able to
get major policy stuff done but they're
trying and I think tax reform will get
through so see on that and then and then
D on communication and I'm gonna give
you why it's it's young communication in
just a second let me show you just
another example of bad communication
from the White House and why this
matters what's the argument the White
House could make that would actually be
what's the way the White House needs to
position itself if they actually hope to
win reelection in 2020 but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
upside comm so upside comm is all about
the best way to travel for work that
business trip that you're about to book
you need to do it with upside comm for a
couple of great reasons first of all you
get a free pair of Bose Soundlink
wireless headphones so you can have some
peace and quiet on the business trip and
second you're gonna get the best
business trip experience that's what
it's like it upside calm they have a
customer service specialist who looks
out for you every step of the way on
your business trip they'll handle any
problem that might pop up you can call
them you can you can talk to them by
chats you can email them whatever you
need them 24/7 its concierge care only
upside monitors your business trip
around the clock
they will proactively keep you posted on
the weather and the city you're going to
changing your flight home so you can
adjust your meeting schedule you don't
get this sort of care from any other
travel website they basically leave you
to your own devices and if something
gets screwed up tough you eat the cost
that's not what upside calm is all about
that concierge cares makes you make sure
that you have the best business trip
possible and they have great prices for
flights hotel and rental car go right
now use mic promo code been when you
booked your first business trip at
upside calm use that promo code band and
you get a free pair of Bose Soundlink
wireless headphones so again code been
at upside calm claim my free gift to you
Bose Soundlink wireless headphones
they're available while supplies last
must be your first upside purchase $600
minimum purchase required and you can
see the site for complete details by the
way any business trip round trip is
gonna cost you 600 bucks so you just go
and book a trip over at upside comm
because it is the best way to travel
upsides a comma again use that promo
code band and when you do and you make
the minimum purchase and it's your first
time then you get those Bose wireless
headphones which is pretty great okay so
the the Trump administration and
President Trump he's very gifted at
sounding off against his enemies it's
what he's very good at okay they put the
most flattering spin on it the President
of the United States finds enemies and
he hits them he doesn't always hit them
in the most appropriate way in
he hits them in some pretty morally
egregious ways he will say things that
are not true about them but he's very
good at putting his opponents in a box
right he hits and he hits any hits until
they are down in the corner whimpering
that's what he did in 2016 election
cycle during the primaries that's what
he did during the general with Hillary
Clinton it is not enough to make your
opponent look like the villain you have
to look like the hero in politics if you
want to get young people particularly to
vote for you it can't just be you saying
the other guy is bad it has to be you
saying the other guy is bad and this is
why he's bad and this is why I'm good
ready actually need to make an
affirmative case for yourself Trump
never makes an affirmative case for the
administration instead he only makes
negative cases the problem is now if he
looks like a villain attacking other
villains and young people have the sort
of foe cynicism about politics where
everyone's a bad guy except Bernie
Sanders everyone's a bad guy except Rand
Paul right whoever is the most kind of
out-of-the-box candidate who is
perceived to be pure as the driven snow
those are the candidates that that young
people like and that's because they
perceive them as the heroes of these
particular morality plays everyone who
votes sees politics as a morality play
even people who are 60 you voted for
Trump in the last election cycle see
more SEC politics is morality play they
just see it as a deeply immoral morality
plane which Hillary Clinton is the devil
and Trump is the devil you know in order
to feed the devil you don't I think that
was the majority of people who voted in
the last election cycle the people who
loved Trump were able to somehow fit
Trump into the hero box which I don't
understand how you could do that in the
last election cycle maybe it was just
because he was hitting Hillary Clinton
that alone gave him the title hero as
opposed to sort of antihero in any case
what Trump needs to do if he wishes to
win the 10 million additional votes that
he's gonna need between now and the next
election cycle in reelection is he needs
to show people that he is not just anti
media but that he is Pro truth he needs
radical Islam but that he is Pro truth
about Islam he needs to show people that
he is not just anti-big government but
that he is Pro a limited government view
of the future right now that's what
President Trump needs to do and if you
won't do it then the vice president
needs to do it if the vice president
won't do it then other members of the
administration need to do it
the bottom line is that you cannot
constantly project your most nasty
negative face and hope that you're going
to win over young people who are
idealistic enough that they will just
stay home or vote third party all right
this holds true for the other side to
Hillary Clinton thought that she
when just by bashing Trump it didn't
work young people did not show up to
vote for Hillary Clinton because Hillary
said I'm not Trump and young people said
we don't care ok the same thing is true
for Trump if he wants to win over people
who are under the age of 50 then he's
gonna have to actually start making
affirmative case for himself
unfortunately he's uncomfortable doing
that I think he's uncomfortable sort of
putting himself out there because it
does take a little bit of vulnerability
to put out your own views it takes a
little bit of vulnerability not to play
the villain but to but to try and be
sincere about the the views that you
hold you know when you go out there I
know because I speak on a regular basis
when I go out there and I attack when
you're on attack there's very little
vulnerability when you're on the
offensive
you're not very vulnerable because the
other person is on the defensive but
when you put out your own viewpoint when
you put out your deeply held beliefs and
you subject those to attack and assault
that takes some real strength it's
harder to do and I think that it's also
what wins you the most points in the end
if you can do both you can attack where
it's necessary to attack and you can
prop up a vision build a vision for the
country at the same time
that's how you win that's what Ronald
Reagan did I think in his first
tournament with George W Bush said
Donald Trump needs to do that Donald
Trump is not doing that right now
I'm gonna explain what he did wrong
yesterday on Twitter and how it's gonna
blow back I know they're a bunch of
people who are saying it's genius genius
Mathematica genius it was not I will
explain in just a second but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire.com and subscribe for $9.99 a month
you can get a subscription to Daley
wire.com when you do you get the rest of
my show live on video you get the rest
of Michael Knowles's show live on video
you got the rest of mandrill clayman's
show live on video you're part of my
mailbag tomorrow my will answer live
questions yes about pudding but also
about other topics over in the live
mailbag if you subscribe so make sure
you go over and do that for the annual
subscription $99 a year cheaper than a
monthly subscription you also get this
the very finest in all beverage vessels
the leftist tiers hot or cold daily
wired tumblr world famous often imitated
never duplicated go check it out right
now plus you'll get discounts at the
Shapiro store which is shortly to be
unleashed upon the world and we have all
sorts of fun things that are coming fun
cheeky things that are coming so that
will be quite wonderful also if you just
want to listen later
iTunes SoundCloud please subscribe to
our YouTube channel we have lots of cool
video content coming out for the
holidays so check that out and we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so yesterday president from tweets out a
buncha retweets a bunch of random tweets
from these this white supremacist
account basically in the UK and it was a
bunch of videos of Muslims doing bad
stuff and it's not smart and it's not
good politics and it's really done a lot
of people on the road no look it's just
it's secret genius as I heard yesterday
from no less than our own Andrew Klavan
through the grapevine and Michael moles
through the grapevine that this was just
it was a work of magnificent
unparalleled genius guys who are this
close to being fired that is so stupid
the reason that this is so stupid is
because the what their suggestion was
that Trump had tweeted out all of these
idiotic videos because Trump was trying
to distract from the tax reform debate
number one why would you want to
distract from the tax reform debate when
you're about to win and two if you
actually want to distract with something
why would you use these videos from this
woman who I guess has been jailed but
she's been jailed because she was
supposedly engaged in hate speech why
would you use that as the excuse so
Knowles and claim like well he was
trying to stand up for free speech in
Britain yes I'm sure that's Donald
Trump's top priority at the moment is
standing up for free speech in Britain
or alternatively here's what happened
they're a bunch of people who tweet at
him at his his username and he sits in
the Oval Office and when he sees
something he likes he retweets it that's
it that's the whole thing you know in
which do you think is more plausibility
sitting there he's going I have I have a
chest strategy to distract from my
winning tax reform play my strategy is
that I will kill two birds with one
stone
I will retweet a bunch of random not
true videos and in some of these cases
the videos and one video particularly
apparently was debunked I will retweet
all of this stuff and I will do it
specifically because I will kill two
birds with one stone I will fight for
free speech rights if some Rando in
Britain and I will also distract from
this ongoing tax reform debate which
isn't hurting me in any way it's all
genius woohoo
not only that I will start a fight with
Theresa May a political ally of mine in
the UK
Rachel Risa may as part of the
Conservative Party she was part of the
brexit party handed like what if you
think that this is if you think this is
in any way beneficial to Trump you're
wrong as I said yesterday the media are
a bunch of cats and Trump has the laser
pointer point the laser in the right
place
the laser in the right place there are
so many ways in which President Trump
could draw real moral contrast between
himself and other people
this is not the way to do it now he's in
an open fight with Theresa May so
yesterday
Sarah Huckabee Sanders was asked
specifically about these about the the
tweets that Trump had made and here was
her answer and that's what the president
is talking about is the need for
national security the need for military
spending and those are very real things
there's nothing fake about so the videos
are fake but the threat is real okay
that you don't get to do this in
politics okay you want to know why
president that here that the polls show
that the media are not trusted with
regards how they cover President Trump
the polls also show that people trust
the media more than they trust Trump
Trump is in a great job of tearing down
the media he has not done a good job of
propping up and it's Ted something true
and something real and it's not good for
him when he's getting in fights with his
own allies yesterday on the floor of the
House of Commons the British actually
raised a point of order about Trump's
tweets here's what it looked like on the
House of Commons floor yesterday even
doubting Thank You mr. speaker and for
exceptionally taking this and you may
not be aware mr. speaker nor others in
the house but it appears that the
President of the United States has in
recent moments urbeats retweeting
comments from far-right organizations in
Britain first highly inflammatory videos
including some posted by an individual I
believe has recently been arrested and
charged relating to certain serious
offenses and I wondered whether you have
noticed mr. speaker of any intended
statement by the Home Secretary or the
foreign sector on this very serious
matter absolutely I confess I have no
advance notice of this matter I am NOT
my self one who tends to follow what is
said on Twitter okay so there is point
aboard in the House comments and Trump
fires back he goes after Teresa may the
Prime Minister of Britain and he tweets
this he says Theresa May don't focus on
me focus on the destructive radical
Islamic terrorism that is taking place
within the UK we are doing just fine um
why are you getting a fighter recently
she's your political ally why would you
do that why is that a useful thing to do
they're a bunch of people yesterday
saying this shows that Trump's really
his game he's really on the ball like
well no it doesn't it shows that he's
getting in fights with his own allies
why is that a smart thing to do and by
the way we're not doing just fine on
radical Islamic terror I mean there was
a terrorist who just killed a bunch of
people in New York the other day this is
it's it's you know Trump is doing better
than Obama in on it no question but just
this is useless and it's not setting him
up to be the good guy you want him to be
the good guy the president people want
their president to be the good guy they
don't want the president to be a bad guy
there's no such thing as a two-term
president who was perceived widely to be
the bad guy even Richard Nixon in 1972
this is pre Watergate was perceived to
be a good guy in 1972 seriously go back
and look at the campaign he wasn't just
a bad guy who's defeating George
McGovern okay time for some things I
like and some things I hate and the big
idea will try to fit as much of the soon
as possible so things I like I started
watching mine hunter on Netflix in about
three and a half episodes in it is quite
good it's very graphic it is rated rqx
it's the there's some graphic sex for no
reason the graphic sex is completely
superfluous to the plot but it's like oh
we're Netflix so we're gonna show a
naked chick on screen and then there are
a couple of crime-scene photos that are
pretty graphic I used to work on in DA's
office so I've seen worse than this but
it's a really interesting show the basis
of the show is these two guys from the
FBI who that they've never done any
serial killer profiling so they decide
to go around interviewing serial killers
to determine what exactly makes serial
killers tick so they can help profile
and identify them before they kill again
and here's a little bit of the the
trailer it's not easy butchering people
it's or work physically and mentally I
don't think people realize you need to
then
[Music]
you know there's a lot more like me do
you think so 40 years ago your FBI was
founded hunting down John Dillinger now
we have extreme violence between
strangers we travel around the country
and teach FBI techniques to cops you
guys mind if I bother you for a minute
she was found cuffed and lashed to the
bed what people won't do to each other
there's nothing people won't do how come
we out we should be using every resource
we can talking to the smartest people we
find from the series is actually quite
good and and and very compelling the two
main characters in the series are a guy
who's kind of a nerdy guy who's very
into the vagary of all of this and a
kind of hard charging cop type so far
also the first three and a half episodes
are very good all of the compelling
scenes virtually all of the compelling
scenes are the interviews with the
actual serial killers those are those
are pretty interesting ok so so that is
that's a show that's worth watching if
you can stomach the graphic it's it's
one of those shows that I don't think
that my wife will enjoy too much but it
is quite good if you like Silence of the
Lambs is the kind of show for you okay
time for some things that I hate or
anything I mean okay so this thing I
hate is actually a thing I sort of love
there's a Michigan Democrat who is
running for Attorney General in the
state of Michigan her name is Dana
Nestle and she is running an ad all
about why she is qualified for higher
office the reason she says she is
qualified for higher office is because
she does not have a penis no I am not
kidding this is an actual ad that is
actually on the internet and is actually
running and Israel and this is real life
and what the hell is happening in the
last few weeks has taught us anything
it's that we need more women in
positions of power not less so when
you're choosing Michigan's next Attorney
General ask yourself this who can you
trust most not to show you their penis
in a professional setting
is that the candidate who doesn't have a
penis
I'd say so some people will tell you I
let it be the Democratic that's bridge
for attorney general here in Michigan
because we can't have an all-female
ticket for statewide office in 2018
pundits and insiders are asking can we
afford to have a female governor a
female Attorney General and a female
Secretary of State well I read the news
and I bet you do too and it has me
wondering can we afford not to now if
you want to know more about what I'll do
is Michigan Attorney General head to
Dana
20:18 dot my goodness but right now I
want to tell you what you can expect me
not to do have a penis not so you wait I
will not have a penis no matter what
happens that not happening there will be
no penis you know I hope that she
doesn't become a transsexual in which
case she'd have to add one but in any
case I don't want to find people's
gender for them and then hey this is a
thing now so I guess that the way this
is going to work that men are the evil
gender females are the great gender we
never have to worry about women being
corrupt in office or doing anything bad
in office or covering up for sexual
harassment like Nancy Pelosi for years
we won't have to worry about any of
those things because they because women
don't have penises and penises are bad
penises make you terrible which is an
amazing thing and the penises make you
terrible because I have been reliably
informed that there are many women who
have penises I've been reliably informed
of this Caitlyn Jenner was a woman with
a penis how dare are you he's just
normative heteronormative okay so yes
this is the culture in which we live
okay time for a quick exploration of the
big idea so one of the things that Trump
has been going around saying is that
welfare recipients are making more than
some people who work their butts off
that welfare is a system that actually
denigrates work this is true okay the
left has been very upset about Trump
saying this sort of thing how dare
Republicans say that the welfare system
benefits people who don't work as much
it benefits people who don't work as
much and I will show you a chart
demonstrating this first here is what
Trump had to say about it
I know people they work three jobs and
they live next to somebody who doesn't
work at all
and the person who's not working at all
and has no intention of working at all
is making more money
doing better than the person that's
working his and her ass off and it's not
gonna happen
okay so this is a case where Trump is
actually doing the right thing right
well Trump is saying is I'm standing up
for the working person I'm not gonna
stand for the deadbeat right I'm not
gonna stand for the person who can work
but won't so let me show you a chart of
how welfare benefits work in the United
States so this is the DC ER but this
comes courtesy of the Urban Institute in
Washington DC Circuit 2014 this talks
about tax and transfer benefits for
universally available in additional
programs for a single adult with two
children in 2015 what you see is that if
you earn nothing if your wage is zero if
your wages zero you will make almost
$30,000 in tax and transfer benefits for
universally available and additional
programs and then you see that it sort
of goes down and then it hits a cliff at
about a little under thirty thousand
dollars when you hit that cliff the
total amount drops suddenly it's twelve
thousand dollars right so you're making
a little under thirty thousand dollars
suddenly it's twelve thousand dollars of
benefits that you're making so what you
end up with and this this sometimes
happens is that it is actually
beneficial for you to work less right
you'd prefer to make twenty six thousand
dollars as opposed to twenty seven
thousand dollars on this chart if you
make twenty six thousand dollars
twenty-five thousand dollars you're
still pulling in seventeen thousand
dollars in benefits so let's say you're
making twenty six and you pull in
seventeen and benefits assuming
forty-three total if you earn thirty or
or you earn twenty-eight or twenty-seven
and you pull in twelve twenty seven and
twelve is 39 so you're actually going to
make about the same amount of money for
working less and in some cases
significantly less money for four for
working more these programs are are
difficult to administer it's difficult
to find the balancing point and it is
certainly true that the work
requirements that are on welfare need to
be strengthened by Congress they should
be strengthened because otherwise you
have these income cliffs in which we are
encouraging people not to work so Trump
is not wrong about this the welfare
system has been a great a great impetus
to people working less over the history
of the program
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow
they're supposed to vote on tax reform
either today or tomorrow so we should
have some big news for you then i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex Zingara audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jo
opera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2017